[音楽]
寂しいところコーナー
バッハ
っていう大変お待たせしました質問コーナーで募集期限を越えてからめちゃくちゃ
コメントだったんですけども5合計は皆さまのおかげで20万コメントを超えました
本当にありがとう
ございました1人じゃあ見れませんでしたちょっとで20万コメントはちょっとさすが
に一人だと無理でした8月いっぱいをもっておくん子を旅立つ弟と一緒にコメントを見
させていただきました本当にたくさんのコメントありがとうございました
その最後でゆるくてきた御質問コーナーいきましょう
ヴィッツ芸立つに挨拶して本町
こんにちははじめ社長ですの逆ですわーわー
今すごい出向いてみましょうおまけない初投稿です
誠実ながらドキドキのはず質問をさせていただきありがとうございます
なんかドキドキするね採用しろよ俺
はい
ななんなんだこの人はアイコンとのギャップがひどすぎるコメント20万ってすごい
ですな
俺のコメントは頭に底の方へ沈んでることでしょう俺は君がどこに居男
何度でも
見つけてあげる
[音楽]
本写真元気にやってるか写真じゃねえは元気だよおい写真
意外と動画面白いなあこれからもがんばり安いんじゃねばありがとう
おいそうだったらいいおい針金ちょいをするらしいよ2台アルミだったり面白いそこの
白滝せるべきじゃねえはもう何で頑張れ0 e 0
頑張る音や500個じゃねえば何でもいいとギャリーみたいなこの風潮はなんだけ火を
愛して
me
もうちょっとコメントします始めも常にどう見てるに感謝してホントすごいなーって
思います本当尊敬してます
あと納豆版だから食べてください
妻へディオ位イオン
4日 riccia なぁ零戦創センパイ許すチェンジ見せてやだまりとまずな質問
するはここ山にすごい気になって朝も起きられないことだ
実際将生とできてるできてねは来年こそ初めに会うたびに受験勉強を頑張っています
待っててねもう頑張ってありがとう待ってるよ
本当に頑張ってね本気で部活やみたいですでも同級生は僕を含めて2人しかいなくて
止めると負担をかけてしまいますでもその人は自分のうまくいかないことがあれば僕に
当たって態度すごい帰ってきますそれに今後も強いして宗基
どうすればいいですかアドバイスとかお願いしますぅ
んじゃないことをやった方がいいと思います辞めたいと思ったらやめましょうはやり
たいと思ったらやりましょうただまぁいう気にしてちゃ本当に何もできなくなっちゃう
んで
もう何にも気にせず自分の思ったことをやったらいいと思います os ではお寿司の
中で何が一番好きですか
光の魔王と闇の魔法を組み合わせる部分で打ってどのようなことが起こるのですかね
ってるの葉茶言ってってっていいっ
知ってぺぺーに鉄平さん
二を辞めようおい何でやらしたお前キーワード
kokonoe 選挙民のやめろ
者に入っの味の金も
一粒コメントデー
世界が救われた瞬間がバナナ清純になってください
えっ
好きな数字はいいよ来いよいくや自分
フォア優子4 f 行く奴は日本語で日本語で日本語で日本語でやーん
pets 他の女の子とかナムの面目
私だけ見てるって言ったもんだめです他の女の子と絡むの女
ペチペチぷうと頬した全力で母親のよ帰ってください
母のミュオン会が内容によって僕も家に帰れなくなりますからね笑顔ならきっと許して
くれるので髪の毛がちなみにショートヘアなんですよまず自分の絵を描くて難しいな
難しいけど多分大体こんな感じだと思いますかあさんが
コメントの数すごいなお前質問はないはい質問はない
第が初めに一つ言いたいことがある
ベーコンはいおっぱいや好きですか第一第二期ね誰だよ私の名前は先と言うんですけど
だんだんありません
はじめしゃちょー私にはどんなくださいさっきちゃんか
さきちゃんなら例えば察知さっちゃ
うんこ笹尾山太郎弾み雪をじゃないけどさっき
みんなやめろ源さんツイッターでなんで女の人ばっかにめっぽう降るんですが音が出
もっと返してくれー
これよく言われるんですけどもツイッターの僕のディプランを見てもらったら分かるん
ですけどもほぼ8池よりお金なのかです
ロード見てくれているのは男の子の方が多いんですけどもやっぱツイッターは女の方が
すごく多いんだよとこのみんなもっとリプはポケテレ
電マをデンマークに送るなっちゃったせいか13キーなくしゃみ
場所たの流通
おいはじめいい加減にゴミ箱から出ないよ
オドとにキスして
[音楽]
王を取ったら空くはず生
アビエルファロはじめ9対1にピポパパっちよりプレッション台湾美龍館2対1
ビッグワンデー knb d を間フィット a 町
引退まあ夕飯目に fun to play alone 台湾 p とハロー
ああ今8ねぇ i love スパイ番アイバーの50あーあーはーねああいう
ハッピーなーい
祖父のお前ははじめじゃないかそっかいう変態取った地面ドゥユーラヴにやっぱり w
誰だよ肇社長 i love ストマジ iphone の cd と会話して
ブーブーところが白くジョズトゥルン
バイバイこのコメント読んでくれたらいいなぁほぼ日本語じゃない口をされたんだけど
したを最大に出した状態で半額っていうすることは一部の人しかできない私もやってみ
てください
[音楽]
まあ顔キモはマターでをやれ
小指を過度にぶつけるわけわからん
wh
うわぁ
お願いですもっと品登場しますバイバイ
[拍手]
は1
rar
ああああああはワンマンはーう子を持ってりゃ
さーんっ
ザーッとメイクにデーまでマジギレしてうわー
tomoya
己をてなぁ
こちらねーの
最後にみんなでアコワゴ入っ
ずっと不安定になってくだちうー
あったんだこれをするメリットを考えた時
始めまーす
何も思いつからこれマジで凄いから始めやってみてください
言わず何でもいいので好きな数を覚え浮かべてください
思い浮かべましたかではその数に用を足してください2両を出したはず2級を足して
その他して陣地を引いてください
そんな数に子を足して16をかけてくださいするとなんとなんと
何度ですねいい
時間が無駄になりました弟に一撃
[音楽]
みんな乳首が燃えたよう
弟にお湯をかけてー
[音楽]
あっ放ち3 e
ちぃー
ちみぃ1 b 不平
皆さんいかがだったでしょうか質問コーナーでございました今回でもう結構かなりの
コメントを作業したのでなかなかを急ぎ足になっちゃったんですけれども本当に皆さん
面白いコメントいつもありがとうございますまたね以降はなんかよ期待むき出しつも
コーナーできたらぜひ皆さんコメントお待ちしております
皆の衆夏休みが終わってもいろいろ
あまりましょうじゃあ
[音楽]
いっ
ん
オープン
んをっ
me
ん
[音楽]